[Music]
let's go to melissa in new canaan
connecticut hey melissa what's going on
hi dr john how are you i'm good how are
you
i'm great such an honor to speak with
you today dr john very big fan i promise
you the honor is
is mine i i assure you
what's up i'm so grateful that you
called what's up
so dr john i'm
i'm calling uh just having kind of a
two-layered issue i hope that you can
help me with so basically i'm a native
buffalonian from buffalo new york
um i was home visiting my parents this
past week when the mass shooting at tops
occurred
um that occurred in the neighborhood
where i went to school
i knew people that grew up there and i
second hand know one of the victims
so all this
you know like so many others it's been
very difficult for me to process to
think about
much else since it occurred
and i'm kind of taken aback and how much
it's affected me yeah um the more
complicated layer to this is that i'm
actually a counseling student i'm doing
clinical mental health counseling yes
yeah and i'm about to start my practicum
i want to specialize in trauma
counseling but i'm struggling with
what's happened in buffalo yeah
i'm at a loss i don't even know what i
would say if a client needed to speak to
me about this because truthfully i'm
scared too i'm afraid for my parents to
just be living there now to go to the
supermarket
just kind of live their lives and you
know do normal routine things that we
have to do out and about
so you know i the whole thing with this
is i wish i could speak to someone about
this um because i do feel like i'm
struggling but i'm hesitant to say
anything to people especially those that
are in my cohort or my professors
because i wouldn't want them to think
that i'm now unfit for their confident
profession oh man so i'm calling um dr
john to see if you have any advice on
how i can process this
and also not lose faith in my own
abilities as a counselor i think i've
always prided myself on being a pretty
level
headed and calm person but honestly this
has really rattled my sense of security
there's a lot here
um
so the first i think it's important just
to pause for a second okay and
what happened in buffalo was evil
and it was
senseless doesn't even it's so out of
mind it's in the insanity right
um
and
being from there this is different than
a news headline this becomes home right
yeah
and knowing people this becomes
like this becomes in your chest this
isn't just in your head anymore right
and so
i think it's important to just stop for
a second honor the folks who have passed
um yeah honor the folks who showed up
there and got in the middle of all that
mess
so i'm gonna tell you a story i was
working
crisis work um so i would be i was a
dean of students um by day and then at
night um
i was
working with the local police department
and what we're doing is doing death
notifications and all that kind of stuff
right you've probably heard me talk
about that
yeah um
so my daughter was two
and um for everybody listening this is a
very very hard story to hear and so i
know that um and i'm i'm being
intentional i'm not trying to be
gratuitous here yeah um
my daughter was two
and i and i my son was about i guess he
was eight at the time and like you i
prided myself on how tough i was and not
even that i was that tough but i could
just walk into any situation and see the
craziest stuff
and um i got a call and it
it was just a text message on my phone
that said hey this is what we appears to
happen 10 16 looks like somebody's
passed away
and we need to show up to the hospital
and so i just knew when i showed up to
hospital that usually means that my job
was going to be sitting with
parents um or loved ones
and i showed up to the hospital and
somebody caught me in the hallway and
they said hey here's what's happened
there was a daycare
and it was in an um
about 45 minutes away in a rural area
and they had 15 kids but they were
driving around um toddlers um and they
were driving around
and there was two young people that were
working at this place and they took the
van and they parked it
and they got all the kids out
but they left the two in the back seat
they forgot them
and they stayed in that texas heat
and i
one of them had passed away already and
when i got there was one more on life
support
yeah and mom was 20. my mom was 19 and
dad was 20.
and i walked in
and
here's all i saw
i saw a crowd of people around this
little girl
all i saw was her arm
and
yeah it was from her elbow to her
fingers and i'll remember that picture
in my head as long as i live
and
i had to leave
yeah because that looked like my baby
girl's arm
yeah i had to get out okay
and i felt a lot of shame about that i
felt embarrassed about that my partner
janiece she's one of the greatest women
i've ever known she's incredible and i
looked and said i gotta go and she said
you cannot leave me here that's that's
101 right and i said i cannot be here
and that happened one other time i think
i've talked about the show but all it to
say is i had to leave and it was a
visceral body reaction and here's why
i'm telling you that story
i did trauma for a living still do
yeah
but that one was home
yeah
and there's it's important for you as a
growing therapist as a new counselor to
understand that our job is to wade into
other people's messes
and there are seasons when other people
need to wait into hours
yeah so the greatest gift you can give
your professor and your cohort is to say
this has broken me for a season
yeah i'm hurting
and what that's
it's it's it's not only not gonna hurt
your professional character and fitness
to be a therapist it's gonna humanize
you and give you a different layer when
somebody comes in and says i'm scared
you're gonna be able to go yeah i know
you see what i'm saying
yeah i do and so
this is a great gift what i would tell
you as a therapist you have to have
people that you can talk to
yeah did you grow up in a situation
where you needed to just be stoic about
stuff
absolutely
i i definitely did you know um my my
parents are are immigrants and you know
where they're from you just don't talk
about that kind of stuff i you know i
myself have
been on the other side of the chair and
i've been you know in therapy and i know
how healing it can be and that's why i
wanted to become a therapist myself but
i sort of feel like when i entered the
profession
maybe dr john you can tell how much of a
rookie i am i almost felt like
now i can't be you know that client so
to speak i i kind of have to
be strong and and and know it all to be
able to survive in this profession quite
frankly is you know i i'm not able to to
fall apart at everything and
um you know we're here to help people
through the worst moments of their lives
and for me it's just
it hurts like you were saying i think
it's kind of that both and situation um
it's just
i try and talk to my husband about it
you know but he's not from buffalo i
think really only people from there
might truly be able to understand how
completely painful this is for our city
and how disgusting it is on so many
levels
um but i i do
wish that i kind of had
an outlet
of someone to speak to because i don't i
also didn't want to dump on my husband
and you know have him play therapists to
me
that's right
it's been difficult
you are
conflating life with your profession
yeah and i want you to untangle that
you're hurting
and this is going to require collective
morning for the city
this is going to require collective
grief for our country
this is going to require a lot of grief
for you
yeah
and that doesn't make you not a great
professional this will be something that
you'll make meaning of on the back end
you already want to go be about trauma
and now you have a
a
you your body is telling you what your
clients are going to be telling you for
years
the idea i've worked with police
officers and swat officers and nurses
and doctors and surgeons everyone in
between
counselors of course i teach graduate
counseling courses
yeah what i'll tell you is
those that bottle this stuff up and
think that professionalism looks like
quote unquote it won't get to me
they end up in ash
yeah so much so that my my professors
said if you are a counselor and you do
not have somebody to go talk to
we're gonna consider that unethical
it is a
how in the world can i show up
fully for you when i'm not full when i'm
not whole
right yeah um and so i've got to go sit
with somebody
and i'll tell you this one of the
greatest moments of one of the greatest
breakthrough moments of my life was
sitting with a counselor who i saw him
get tears in his eyes as i was talking
really wow and i remember now i've heard
of stories of counselors weeping through
sessions and the clients are like dude
i'm coming to you man what i mean
so it didn't it didn't that tear didn't
say he's weak that tears showed me he's
with me
yeah and that's a totally different
proposition
often when you grow up in a home where
showing feelings got you hurt or not
even got you hurt we just don't do that
yeah then you're faced with something
then you have a choice and it's really a
crossroads here as a human not as a
counselor as a person am i going to be
somebody that continues this family
generational trauma of bottling stuff up
and sucking it up
or am i going to
learn how to be heard and to say i'm sad
and to say i'm heartbroken and to weep
bitterly
yeah and to not sleep for days on end
and have people in your life that you're
being open with
i'm gonna teach my kids something
different i'm gonna teach my clients
something different i'm gonna change how
this thing works do you see what i'm
saying
i do
so here's what i want you to do
yeah you may not have done this here's
the here's the protocol that i would be
using if i'm in your exact shoes okay
yeah um
can i ask you another personal question
of course are you african-american
no but i am a person of color okay i'm
i'm next i'm yeah but uh so this is
intensely personal yeah yes
yes it is because this person came for
you
that's your body reacting okay do not
run from this what happened is
terrifying and scary and if you'd been
there you would have been on the list is
that is that fair
okay oh absolutely that's one of the
first things that i thought that this is
someone that
would hate me
not hating not even knowing would want
you not alive they want you dead yes yes
yeah that's a that's a different level
right yeah yeah um i hate the atlanta
braves i don't want any of them dead
right this is another level
and so
running from that reality is going your
body will continue to try to solve for
that reality while your mind is trying
to distract itself with other things
yeah and you'll find a golf so here's
what i want you to do
number one you have to be around other
people
and you have to tell your story full
stop okay that can be one person that
can be a professional that can be five
people that can be on a group phone call
i would rather be in person but i know
you don't live in buffalo right so this
is home
um i'm thinking of when i wasn't in
houston where i'm at home and all my
friends and community and family and
hurricane harvey hit and i felt
this panic i was watching my friends
send videos of their houses falling down
and we were on the phone we were talking
i did the best i could and it was still
unnerving and i just let myself be sad
for a while you see what i'm saying
and so i want you to
get on the phone and say i'm not doing
okay
here okay i want you to get a meeting
with your
counseling supervisor
okay and say this happened and this is
my home and i even have a a
one-step relationship away from one of
the victims and i'm really hurting
tell somebody in it tell somebody um
that's got some important mentor role in
your life that okay yeah honor your body
that way okay and listen if that person
if you're a supervisor if she or he says
well i don't know man you're gonna have
to suck it up
dude
they are cashing out i mean they're
they're a terrible terrible mentor
they're not going to say that though
yeah they're going to probably reach
across and say can i hug you and
hopefully you'll say yes if you feel
safe
um
here's number two
yeah i want you to go to walmart amazon
um
barnes and noble whatever and get a
small journal and start writing this
stuff down
okay i want you to write down how pissed
off you are and raged out and angry you
are
yeah i want you to use the shooter's
name
i want you to write down how angry and
sad you are and use the victims names
and talk about your friends and your
mom's still there and your dad's still
there i want you to be really specific
but i want you to write this stuff down
okay yeah
and and
when you have a good day i want you to
write that down too this isn't all about
negativity and awfulness okay
that's true
here's the last thing
here statistically speaking
this is not going to happen again there
in buffalo
i really hope so i'm so afraid that it's
quite cute i know i know but so here's
what i'm trying to say statistically
speaking is probably going to happen
but it might
okay and moving forward in our life
we got to hold that tension
and so
the chance you have to go back and visit
your home
it's important
yeah and we've um i've met with students
who are immigrants and international
students and when there's a great
tragedy they've they taught me this
that's why i ended up going back home
after harvey i had to go be there
yeah and i don't i can't explain it i
don't i don't know any studies i had to
go put my feet on the ground and look
around and say okay the sun is still
shining here yeah and people are still
driving their cars and people are still
laughing and the astros are still losing
like i have to get i got to get there
you know what i mean
so
at some point as hard as that's going to
be i want you to go home
and i want you to hug people real real
tight
and i want you to if you can go visit
the grocery store
here with not alone with okay
and that's a part of your healing
journey to put your feet back on the
ground in that place where home is okay
so in another in a similar but different
scenario
yes i left that hospital that night
and i went home
and you don't dare wake up a sleeping
two-year-old because you know i mean
that i'm going to end up
in a morgue with from my wife
but i went home
and
i went and woke my eight-year-old up
yeah he's half asleep and i hugged him
as hard as i could
that was me going home okay yeah
yeah
and i had to put my hands on him
and feel him and say okay
that's me regulating my body okay
so the three counterpoints here are
connection
writing this stuff down be honest about
your thoughts and feelings
it's the central idea of going home
because this is you this isn't about
trauma some this is about your home and
here's a fourth one make sure you're
taking care of your body move your body
you got to eat you got to laugh you
still got to be into with your husband
if you feel up to it like you got to do
life stuff okay yeah yeah
but do have a season of mourning so i
tell you all that stuff i just threw a
lot at you tell me how that feels as i'm
telling you that are you like oh my god
you're an idiot youtuber or
is this ringing true
no it absolutely rings true and um
you know
you know dr john one of the things that
i've shared in my classes i've also
acted as a ta is is what you've taught
as
periods of life are seasons
you know i i realize that this is like a
season that that i'm going to be sad but
you know i think
the other part of me just feels like i
always need to be strong and it's just
it's difficult
it's difficult let that in today
yeah okay
yeah because one day you're gonna have a
little one
and
something bad bad's gonna happen and
you're gonna immediately go back to that
great stoic we just gotta suck it up
that your parents taught you
yeah
and you're gonna look at that little
little
kid of yours and you're gonna have a
choice
and you can say the way we deal with
pain
is to build up a wall
or
the way we deal with pain is to be sad
yeah and so honey
you get to come see mommy be sad come
hug me because mommy's really sad
because her friend passed away or
grandmother is sick or one of your
friends you see what i'm saying
i want to give the gift too and then
here's where the strength comes in is on
the making meaning side then now what
okay so i'm not advocating that we all
just go and not do anything
there's a season of grief
and for many of us we got to keep going
to work we got bills to pay right yep
there's a season of grief there's a
season of grinding it out
and then as the great david kessler says
there's a season of making meaning so
who am i going to be because of what
i've experienced and what i've been
through and that's not for today okay
that's not for today what you'll do is
you'll go back and look at your journal
uh after a time and you'll start to go
oh i just keep circling up because
you're going to start writing things and
you're going to circle it you're going
to think about it and suddenly you're
going to be like that's who i'm going to
be
yes yes and if i might just add one
thing i think part of what
has made this process difficult for me
is how profoundly angry i feel and um
i think that i'm someone like it takes a
lot for you to rattle me in general but
for me to feel something like rage is
very rare
i felt it maybe only a couple times in
my life not that there's not things in
the world that you know we're angry at
of course but i mean on a personal level
um
i feel rage and it's it's maybe not a an
emotion that i'm not familiar with you
know and so
so i anger is um
anger simply points your body towards
things you care about
yeah
rage is when that anger becomes trapped
and it becomes um
explosive right
and so i want to feel my anger anger is
good it's powerful and it's strong
and then i want to
do things that are going to
honor me and honor my loved ones and
honor my community and honor
what happens next right yeah
so that means i'm going to write that
stuff down i'm going to go for walks i'm
going to take care of my body i'm going
to
be open and tell my story and listen to
other people tell their stories i'm
going to hug and i'm going to weep
and then i might take another class on
trauma
yeah i'm going to take another class on
racist idiots who shoot people right i
mean whatever i'm going to i'm going to
get to the bottom of it right but that's
not right now right now it's just a
season to be sad
yeah okay
i i need you to hear me say this
you're going to make a
incredible therapist someday oh thank
you dr john okay
you are thank you and um
the more vulnerable and more open you
can learn to become in your private life
the better therapist you're going to
become down the road
yeah okay
you're you're so right cool are we same
team
yes sir we are thank you so much dr john
all right i am so grateful to have
gotten a moment to talk to you and
before we leave
um
you've noticed on this show um whenever
somebody calls and says somebody passed
away the first question i was asking is
what was their name
and we have a
challenge in our in our culture we don't
like to say names we like to roll things
off or just use flowery language like
deceased whatever
instead of dead instead of hurt instead
of anger and rage
and so
as always i think it's critically
important
to say people's names
say their name
pearl and ruth
and andre
and roberta
and marcus
and aaron
and geraldine
and celestine hayward
catherine
we gotta do better guys
we're gonna miss y'all
we're gonna do better